this is adorable and terrifying the
grace helbig brand hello welcome to
Friday also known as Saturday re also
known as sometimes Sun diary and mostly
known as the diary of things that have
happened to me throughout the week this
week has been busy and relaxing in both
ways just slowly eating my right eye I
don't know how much actually film this
week so this will be a fun little
journey for both of us to see hey here's
a look back at my week don't mind me
just watching the Panthers game leaning
out of my hotel window cuz it's right
there speaking of another cougar okay so
pre-show rituals
hmm backstage at the Charlotte show no
memories here Knicks yeah yeah I ate let
me see yeah Oh curious there's one
section of this vegetable tray that's
missing it's broccoli yeah well you know
it's true to the cause
yeah that's true see I I like Nick's
optimism memory we are post charlotte
show memory how do you think it went oh
sorry I'm just holding you in the palm
of my hand right now
don't mind me hey girl it was Mary's mom
was in the audience and Mary's mom also
gave us slippers which are the sweetest
gift of all time like what a southern
belle like so so sweet it was a really
fun show and it was the audience was
great and it's always strange on a
Sunday night to see like what what
everyone's like and it was really really
fun
if you guys ever wonder like what our
backstage area looks like it's basically
just like full-on rock star status look
at that just kind of an old fruit bowl
this is like an empty printer case or
like shredder thing full of ice and then
Nick who this creep in Nick's always in
the best mood it makes videos now it
just pan - Nick smile and wave what's a
good business plate number - Nicky -
we are seeing some high art right now my
stepmom are in my dad excited yeah
really excited yeah gonna be high art
just a casual lunch with my parents my
stepmom has a great taste in alcohol
oh hi New York oops you're lovely how do
you look so pretty it smells so nasty at
the same time we're headed to meet some
very special humans get ready it's so
dark
but it's my favorite song with my
favorite people can you get here oh
that's terrifying how's that there's a
wonderful spike in the background yeah
that was really beautiful what just
happened the hair flip with the candle
light I'm gonna slow it down and replay
the numerous numerous dive
he's not looking at me because he knows
I have a real bone to pick with him
I mean talk about a couple of boners
kiss stop what's that I dude I could go
for some relaxation you've got any
joints like there's my vertebrae
guess this guy's favorite actor Nicholas
ribcage that guy seems pretty horny
somebody get those guys some poo pourri
they extinct there you go
there was my week I hope that you
enjoyed this in any way if you did hit
the like button and also if you really
did hit the subscribe button that would
be so cool of you to do also me Marie
and I are headed to Atlanta Georgia for
another this might get weird y'all a fun
event and then we go to Houston and
Tempe so if you live in those areas and
haven't Bart it's Burt your ticker [ __ ]
burger triggers that was my southern
accent it wasn't I am not trying to be
offensive and what else is there to talk
about Grace's guide book calm the book
is still out and proud and floating
around in a lot of social circles get it
in yours and then that's probably
everything that I have to talk to you
about I don't know
yeah